kampf gegen aids gewonnen zahlen zu den
folgen des bienensterbens und 2015 ist
für immer das heißeste jahr das sind nur
drei der fünf themen heute in den klicks
unter pfeifen wird dieses jahr das
heißeste jahr seit anbeginn der
messungen wenn man die letzten wochen
revue passieren lässt könnte da schon
stimmen die nationale ozean und
atmosphäre verwaltung in washington
berichtete von einer oberflächen
durchschnittstemperatur auf den ozean
und den landflächen von 16 33 grad
celsius der durchschnittswert des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts liege fast ein
ganzes grad darunter letztes jahr im
juni konnte der bis dato heißeste tag
seit 1880 gemessen werden aber auch den
haben die temperaturen im vergangenen
juni um 0 12 grad überboten
es ist praktisch unmöglich dass 2015
nicht das wärmste jahr aller zeiten wird
so jesse geplanten klima
wissenschaftlerin der nva
ich glaube keiner würde sich beschweren
wenn es noch nicht nicht noch so ein
heißes jahr geben würde
die krankenhäuser mussten rund um die
uhr patienten mit
kreislaufzusammenbrüchen hitzschlägen
oder ähnlichem versorgen
die enorme hitze forderte auch viele
tote allein im südlichen teil pakistans
starben über 1200 menschen daran
2030 ist der kampf gegen aids gewonnen
am dienstag teilte der un
generalsekretär ban ki moon
voller freude mit die welt hat das
geschafft die aids-epidemie anzuhalten
und zur umkehr zu bringen
es leben derzeit zwar immer noch circa
37 millionen betroffenen menschen auf
der welt aber in den letzten 15 jahren
hat sich vieles getan seit 2000 konnte
die zahl der neuinfektionen um 35
prozent reduziert werden
vor elf jahren starben die meisten
menschen an hiv bis heute konnte diese
zahl fast halbiert werden ban ki moon
sieht somit eines der ziele also der un
ziele als geschafft an vor 15 jahren
wurden ganze acht ziele verfasst das
sechste ziel lautete unter anderem bis
2015 die ausbreitung von hiv/aids zum
stillstand bringen und eine trendumkehr
bewirken
um dieses ziel zu erreichen wurde bis
heute fast 190 milliarden dollar
eingesetzt dieses geld ist wirklich gut
investiert eine weitere erfreuliche zahl
ganze 75 prozent der schwangeren frauen
auf der ganzen welt sind in ärztlicher
jung damit eine noch bessere versorgung
gewährleistet werden kann soll das
jährliche budget von 22 milliarden auf
32 milliarden dollar erhöht werden
die aufstockung des budgets könnte es
mehr menschen ermöglichen medikamentös
behandelt zu werden
in 15 jahren soll der virus vollständig
ausgebremst werden
die erde erwärmt sich das eis schmilzt
klassisches standard klimawandel
szenario nicht aber am nordpol so die
experten am nordpol nahmen das eis
zwischen 2012 und 2013 sogar zu forscher
der university college london
berichteten darüber nature geoscience
fachmagazin betrachtet man den zeitraum
herbst 2012 bis herbst 2013 ist sogar
eine steigerung von über 40% zu erkennen
von 7750 auf 10.000 49 kubikkilometer
eis der großtat 2 satellit zeichnet
schon fünf jahre die aktie mit seinem
radarstrahlen mit seinen radarstrahlen
auf so wie sich manche fische
orientieren mit schallwellen so ähnlich
arbeitet auch der satellit mit den
strahlen erzeugt der wellen anhand des
echos kann der satellit berechnen wie
dick die eisschicht ist beziehungsweise
welches volumen sie hat ein problem das
bisher nicht behoben werden konnte ist
die exakte messung der pakt als flächen
der darauf liegende schnee würde die
messungen stark verfälschen
aktuell würde man aber die forschungen
so gut wie es derzeit möglich ist
betreiben
vor circa einem monat haben wir bei
pixum facts fiction auf unsere facebook
seite und dem missglückten start des
dragon weltraumfrachter berichtet keine
zwei minuten in der luft und schon
knallte es am himmel und es entstand ein
gewaltiger feuerball
der raumfrachter tracken ging in flammen
auf an bord wichtiger nahezu
essentieller nachschub für die
raumstation iss keine personen wurden
bei dem unglück verletzt oder getötet
dragon war unbemannt jetzt gibt es die
ersten statements zu dem unglück eine
stahl strebe soll schuld daran gewesen
sein
der chef des us raumfahrtunternehmen
spacex persönlich äußerte sich dazu es
sieht so aus als sei die strebe
fehlerhaft hergestellt worden
die streber hätte einen helium behälter
fixiert als diese brach löste sich das
behältnis und explodierte bei der
explosion ist ein schaden von mehreren
millionen dollar entstanden
folgen von bienensterben studie nennt
zahlen dass das bienensterben eine große
bedrohung für uns menschen ist sollte
mittlerweile wirklich jedem klar sein
wenn nicht dann jetzt wissenschaftler
der harvard page chen hochschule für
gesundheitswesen haben in der
fachzeitschrift lernst eine studie
veröffentlicht die die zahlen oder die
folgen daraus in zahlen nennt was
passiert wenn alle bienen aussterben der
studie nach gehen dann 23 prozent
früchte 16 prozent gemüse 22 und 22
prozent getreide verloren
die prozentzahlen beziehen sich alle auf
den weltweiten bestand das ist schon
schlimm genug doch die folgen für uns
habe ich ja noch gar nicht genannt neben
dem das mehrere milliarden menschen an
vitamin a und oder an private mangel
leiden würden gäbe es jährlich 142
millionen mehr tote würden nur 50
prozent der bienen aussterben gäbe es
immer noch 700.000 mehr tote mir jetzt
noch nicht verstanden hat wie wichtig es
ist die ihnen zu schützen
der sollte sich mal die zahlen
aufschreiben und einfach nochmal
durchlesen oder sich das video hier oben
anfangen das ihnen sterben bedroht die
menschheit zu rap und zum block kommt
hier unten
und was denkt ihr über einen
menschlichen meilenstein mit denen der
un ist ja mal was ganz anderes als die
üblichen technologischen meilenstein
würde mich mal interessieren und dann
wünsche ich euch jetzt noch ein schönes
wochenende